ukrainian officials say russian missile
and air strikes on water facilities and
the thermal power station have caused
widespread outages across its eastern
regions around kharkiv and in donbass
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
said russia was attempting to deprive
people of heat and light while hakeev's
mayor described the strikes as russian
reprisals for key's recent territorial
gains
on the edge of hakeev city fire crews
battle ablaze at one of ukraine's
biggest power and heating plants
flames in the night sky are the only
source of light as the region is plunged
into darkness
a missile struck an infrastructure site
transformers which served the city of
kharkiv were damaged
ukraine says russian missiles struck
across its east and south destroying
homes with multiple fatalities reported
russia's military denied striking
civilian targets saying it had launched
an offensive against military objects
but keith says russia is retaliating by
air as its infantry loses ground
ukrainian forces are sharing videos of
their arrival in towns occupied for more
than six months
some within kilometers of the russian
border they say they've retaken control
of strategic cities including isium once
a supply hub for the invading army
zuma the main square of israel the
building of the local administration is
still burning
everything around is destroyed but it's
okay
we will restore everything
is
is and will be ukrainian
across the northeast the ukrainian flag
is being unfurled
russian symbols are being torn down and
the cries of glory to ukraine glory to
heroes grow louder
[Music]
let's join uh dw correspondent nick
connolly in kiev welcome nick uh haku
smith described these airstrikes on
power grids as russian revenge for
recent ukrainian successes how
disruptive have they been
well this was quite extreme
yesterday electricity gone in most of
the city as you mentioned there the
heating plant attacked we had images of
people stuck in the metro because
electricity was gone but it seems like
they've been remarkably successful at
bringing back the power um that is
something that's been the kind of
pattern all through this war ukraine's
infrastructure remarkably uh flexible
and able to respond to these challenges
but the heating is going to be the much
bigger problem going into the winter
bringing in heating from further afield
as is possible with electricity is
obviously not going to be realistic and
you know these are huge often apartment
blocks that are totally dependent on
that outside heating being brought in
people don't have their own boilers
don't have their electric heating so
seemingly a very very cold winter ahead
for the people in kharkiv
and we've seen the uh the film images of
ukrainian uh forces apparently
liberating huge sways of territory in
the northeast in in recent days almost
reaching the russian border what are the
soldiers finding in the towns uh they
that they do liberate
they're finding a lot of dumped russian
tech tanks to transporter vehicles but
even high-tech stuff drones and more
complicated systems often with their
manuals left and their base stations so
a lot of tech there that is going to be
useful for the ukrainian army in trying
to understand how to better resist these
systems seemingly the russian forces
without even the time to destroy their
kit let alone take it with them they
found lots of the local residents have
left for russia especially people who
are cooperating with russian authorities
they're taking jobs in the russian
occupational authorities they obviously
scared of retribution or judicial
consequences of what they've done and
we're getting sporadic reports of
torture are the mistreatment of people
there especially people connected to the
ukrainian state people who maybe were
veterans of the ukrainian army but it's
all pretty difficult to report on right
now no real systematic access for
journalists we're just working on social
media and the stuff that's getting
through to us here many of these places
still don't even have a mobile phone
connection so it's all pretty hazy for
now but lots of kind of scratching of
heads here in kiev people not really
able to believe that it was possible to
push the russians back so fast
over such a big area
and a word about the uh the nuclear uh
reactor the nuclear power plant that
russia occupied in zaparisia on sunday
the country's uh nuclear operator said
external power had been restored in
order to close down the the final
reactor uh is that good news
it's good and bad news so obviously you
know drawing down that last reactor
means that if there is a direct hit
there is less of a threat of something
going wrong but it also makes the plant
a lot more vulnerable and a lot more
dependent on the outside world for its
cooling to keep what is already there
safe so right now there's one connection
to the ukrainian grid if that is lost
through some kind of attack like the
ones we've seen in kharkiv in the last
24 hours then they are totally dependent
on diesel generators to keep everything
cool and safe and you know that there is
a lot of skepticism here that it will be
possible over a long period of time to
bring in enough diesel on the scale the
kind of timelines needed so lots of
people here seeing those attacks on
ukraine's electricity system also as a
threat to ukraine and the international
community that the situation zapaja
could get a lot more dangerous for the
world if russia keeps on facing these
kind of losses so a lot of worry about
that here and a lot of talk about
international peacekeepers or some kind
of in outside intervention to prevent
that russian control of this huge power
station europe's biggest atomic power
station from turning to something a lot
more dangerous okay thank you for that
nick and nick connolly in kiev
well we can look at how this is being
reflected in russia with dw
correspondent killian bayer he's part of
our moscow bureau which is currently
operating from latvia's capital riga
welcome to the studio killian how's
russian media reporting these losses
taking place in ukraine
well i think it's clear it's a dramatic
defeat for the russian military and
especially kupiansk and isiam were
strategic railway hubs
and we saw the first reports
for russians really come in through
pro-russian war bloggers on telegram
channels there was quite some harsh
criticism saying the russian army has
abandoned us um it kind of shifted then
to state television we heard and some of
the the the talk shows we heard um
people saying you know oh
there's some bad stuff happening in
ukraine we should all get together and
pray for our soldiers who are fighting
hordes of ukrainian soldiers equipped
with western weapons um
one of the the top talk shows on prime
time you know i think the word don't
panic was
was said about 10 times which kind of
had the opposite effect i kind of felt
now the narrative has shifted and the
ministry of defense put out the
statement that there's a regrouping
happening and that seems to be kind of
the the way things are are being
portrayed but still
there is some a very surprising
outspoken criticism of the way that
russia is conducting the war um also
something that i
found quite surprising is that the word
war is falling more and more often on um
on
national television in russia and this
could of course be a slip of the tongue
because people are are nervous or
surprised by what's happening but maybe
it's also deliberate and uh maybe you
know
the russian public is being prepared for
a mobilization um but it's it's really
hard to say that's just speculation okay
because of course prior to this this has
been described as a special military
operation and and and this
this regrouping as russian local uh
elections have just taken place
has the war been part of campaigning
well you know the the elections are
regional so normally regional politics
don't really look into into foreign
policy but of course um let me just kind
of paint the stage of what was going on
these are huge elections in russia over
82 different regions 31 000 different uh
positions were up for grabs
so you have governors being elected you
have regional parliaments and then you
also have municipal elections uh like in
moscow now the moscow election was
considered by many observers to be also
kind of like a poll on the war um united
russia which is kind of the the
pro-kremlin party kind of a basis of
putin's power
um they they watch carefully how people
vote for them
and kind of take criticism to heart it's
seen as one of the last ways you can
really kind of show dissent towards the
government um but
so the thing is the we haven't seen
really all of all the results come in
yet from moscow
but what we can say is that um
the amount of people voting has uh
doubled so from 2017 there was about 15
percent of people that voted now it's
been 32. okay thank you for that killian
killian bayern riga
you